Hey everybody, I am genuinely glad that you
are with me today.
Uh, even the trolls, we're going to send me
really angry messages.
We have big news today in the category of
this might make Trump loses mind as I call
it.
Donald Trump's oldest son, Donald Trump jr
has been subpoenaed to testify by the Senate
intelligence committee and it's important
to remember that Republicans control the Senate
and therefore they control the Senate intelligence
committee.
The Chairman of the Senate Intelligence Committee
is Republican Richard Burr, but it has actually
been that committee, one of the few places
where there seems to be some sort of bipartisan
logic and dealing with the, the fiasco that
is Donald Trump.
And specifically the Senate Intelligence Committee
wants Donald Trump Jr to show up and under
oath to answer questions about what were obviously
lies.
The last time he testified before the committee,
um, related to his involvement in the Trump
tower Moscow deal, which ultimately didn't
end up going forward.
And Donald Trump jr previously testified about
that issue.
And he lied.
I mean, he, he claimed that he had limited
knowledge about that project.
He claimed that there was never really a plan.
It was never really anything more than a notion
that Michael Cohen thought up and never really
touched a Donald Trump jr in any way.
But unfortunately, since Donald Trump, jr
told those lies to the Senate Intel Committee,
um, we've found out that jr was lying.
There were significant plans for Trump tower
Moscow, a site had been selected, a builder
had been selected, there were architectural
print plans.
There were many meetings about it.
And maybe most importantly, as it relates
to Trump, Trump Jr's involvement, uh, individually,
we heard from Donald Trump's former attorney,
Michael Cohen, who's now in prison, um, that
he was personally briefing both Donald Trump
jr and Ivanka Trump, uh, and others about
this Trump tower Moscow project.
And he talked about it happening at least,
or roughly 10 times.
Here's just like a few seconds from that testimony
under questioning from congressman, Steven
Lynch, with his delightful Boston accent
or the family members that you briefed on
the Trump tower Moscow project.
Don Trump jr and Ivanka Trump.
Okay.
Now with these in the regular course of business,
or did the president or family request the
briefings, this is in the regular course of
business.
Do you recall, um, there's a question on the
number of briefings.
Do you recall how many they might have been?
I'm sorry, sir.
Do you recall how many of these briefings
there might've been?
It's approximately 10.
Okay.
In total.
All right.
This is the opposite of what Donald Trump
Jr said under oath.
And now the leaders of the Senate intelligence
committee who don't like being lied to, including
Republican Richard Burr ranking member, Democrat,
Mark Warner, they want Donald Trump jr to
show up again.
Now, the fact that there is even a subpoena
is significant here because it implies that
Donald Trump jr already either ignored or
rejected, rejected a non subpoena request
to appear, which arguably forced the committee
to issue the subpoena if they actually are
determined to get them, uh, to answer questions
once again.
And so this is newsworthy for a few different
reasons.
One of those is that, again, this is a Republican
led committee and last night I was wondering
is this going to cause infighting between
Trump and his administration and the Republicans
in the Senate and it immediately has a source
close to Donald Trump.
Jr has said to CNBC that this is an obvious
PR stunt from a so called Republican senator.
If you want the truth from Trump jr if you
don't want him lying you now, are apparently
only a so called Republican according to individuals
close to Donald Trump jr.
So the infighting is starting right away.
The expectation is that Trump junior is going
to fight the subpoena if possible and the
funniest little game they're playing is the
following.
CNBC is reporting that the person close to
Trump jr who is commenting about this says
Don is a private citizen now who has already
been cleared by special counsel Robert Mueller
after a two year investigation.
Are they really that dumb?
Because there are endless other investigations.
What I and others said, as soon as the Mueller
investigation up wrapped up was there are
12 to 14 maybe even more depending on sort
of where the lines are between investigations.
There are more than a dozen other investigations.
This isn't the end.
They're going to keep talking to witnesses
and a lot of people on the right said, David,
come on, it's over.
This is it.
There's nothing else.
And then now as we see, the Senate Intelligence
Committee wants Donald Trump junior back and
the argument they're making is he's already
been cleared by Robert Mueller.
That's one of like 15 different investigations
that are going on.
The Mueller probe was one thing.
Did they really think that it was all just
going to go away with the submission of the
Mueller report or is this also a PR game that
they are playing more to curry favor with
the public than to actually convince anybody
who's in a position of power?
I don't know, but the most important takeaway
here is for a Republican led committee to
subpoena the son of a Republican president
in the middle of all the chaos that's going
on now with the Mueller report with William
Barr, they must believe that Donald Trump
jr lied to them.
Senators don't like being lied to if there's
one.
So if we think about like the different echelons
of priority among egotistical elected officials,
very high on the list is uh, they don't like
their power questioned.
Uh, and that is very much entangled with their
partisanship.
They want to be loyal to their party.
One of the things that will more quickly than
almost anything else get Democrats and Republicans
United against some third party is if they
feel that their position of authority and
power has not been respected and showing up
and under oath lying to them, which is what
there was every indication Donald Trump jr
did, is a really quick way to get Republicans
and Democrats working together.
I hope that he shows up.
If he fights the subpoena, we will report
it.
And, uh, we will tell you what ultimately
happens
with this.